[Musique]
une vieille petite ville marchande
typiquement russe qui se trouve au
confluent de trois rivières
ce n'est pas tout à fait en europe mais
pas en asie non plus
constantin est natif de koungou il va au
travail
à la même heure tous les jours
constantin mène des recherches
indépendantes depuis déjà 10 ans pour la
plupart des gens son métier est insolite
mais c'est tout à fait naturel pour les
habitants de l'oural s'est en même temps
risqués et fascinant la réserve
naturelle de la ville
il est tôt le matin constantin profite
de quelques précieuses minutes avant de
plonger dans les ténèbres
salut salut constant pas comment vont
les choses ce matin tout va bien pas de
problème tient à donner les clés un
groupe de scientifiques doit arriver
aujourd'hui pour inspecter soigneusement
d'accord allez un nouveau jour se lève
sur l'un des plus beaux sites de l'oral
tous les jours les gens qui travaillent
sur le site font une dizaine de
kilomètres il y à une coutume ici en
passant chacun doit taper sur la pierre
qui chante plus le son qu'elle produit
et beau plus grandes sont les chances
que le voeu devienne réalité
d'un côté tout semble figé ici mais un
spécialiste peut toujours remarqué le
moindre changement dans la grotte
c'est un organisme vivant est un vrai
paradis souterrain pour les géologues et
les scientifiques en dessous des rives
de la silva au coeur de la montagne de
glace se cache la perle de koungou
[Musique]
la grotte de koungou suscite l'intérêt
de nombreux spécialistes ce n'est pas
étonnant
elle est considérée comme l'une des plus
belles grottes de glace au monde
salut salut et les regarde les
scientifiques qu'on attendait son last
une expédition compliqué ils vont aller
dans la grotte pour y mener des
recherches approfondies
qu'ils aillent assure toi qu'il
s'inscrive bon écoute je vais leur
rencontre pour leur donner les
instructions
la procédure d'enregistrement est
nécessaire afin de s'assurer que tout le
monde est bien sortie de la grotte
aujourd'hui un travail quelque peu
inhabituelle attend ce groupe de
scientifiques peut-être trouveront-ils
une nouvelle grotte ou tomberont-ils sur
un cristal unique dans son genre
selon les estimations des scientifiques
la grotte à entre dix et douze mille ans
c'est la seule grotte de russie doté de
sentiers touristiques
en passant la pierre qui chantent les
chercheurs espèrent découvrir quelque
chose vous devez être très prudent lors
de l' escalade pour ne pas tomber
ça glissait beaucoup de glace la grotte
est grande elle est assez grande
casserole intéressant pour l'oise
si on ne revient pas dans une heure
envoyer quelqu'un nous chercher les
chercheurs sont sur le point de se
mettre à quatre pattes pour entrer dans
la zone de la grotte dont l'accès est
interdit aux touristes ordinaires
bon je vous préviens l'entrée dans la
zone protégée et qu'un trou très étroit
alors soyez prudents olga toi tu iras en
premier faites attention à vous une
cinquantaine de cavernes ont été
découvertes dans la grotte de glace de
koungou re
elle est également célèbre pour ses 70
lac souterrain nicolaï pankov et
biologiste aujourd'hui il étudie la
flore et la faune de la grotte avec son
assistante
olga
leur tâche consiste à poser des pièges
il espère aussi attrapé un habitant de
ses eaux souterraines à mesure que l'on
s'éloigne de l'entrée il fait de moins
en moins froid les températures de l'air
à l'intérieur de la grotte oscille entre
-15 et 4 degrés
[Musique]
oh regardez ce que j'ai trouvé durant
paie quelque part c'est un moustique
divers tricot série d on peut souvent
les voir dans les caves et les plus tu
vois il commence à bouger c'est elle je
ne serais pas surpris s'il s'envole pour
la première fois ces scientifiques ont
la chance d'explorer de près les eaux de
ces lacs
celui ci a été nommé lac des illusions
parce qu'on a l'impression que l'eau y
est en mouvement
mais l'explication est très simple
l'eau provenant des pluies et de la
fonte des glaces s'infiltrent à travers
le glacier et s'égouttent en différents
endroits du lac créant une illusion de
mouvement en termes scientifiques
on appelle cela le phénomène
d'interférences alors maintenant on va
poser un appât le piège on va utiliser
des petits morceaux de ce système à part
je ne dois pas ici ils s'adorent cette
sorte de montgeron jamais de soucis pas
fraîche
il faut plonger un piège tout doucement
pour ne pas le perdre sur allah c'est la
grotte de la tour
elle s'étend sur 121 m l'eau et rod
constamment ses voûtes en gypse et les
contours de la grotte changent
constamment
il est nécessaire de la mesurer
régulièrement nous devons mesurer le
plafond en se basant sur ces résultats
on pourra prédire l'évolution de la
grotte et choisir les voies les plus
sûres pour les visiteurs fine et puis
scheer aujourd'hui les géologues mesure
est l'une des plus belles grottes
elle est unique du fait des différences
de température il gèle en bas tandis que
sous les voûtes
on est au dessus de zéro des stalactites
ne peuvent donc se former dans cette
grotte
il n'y a que des stalagmites
les nicolaï et elena son mari et femme
ils se sont connus alors qu'ils
travaillaient ensemble dans une mine lui
est spécialisée en glissement de terrain
est en travaux de spéléologie comportant
des risques
sa femme est arpenteurs dans les mines
en tant que géologue nicolaï étudie les
différents types de roches décrit leur
formation et leur structure
son travail consiste également à
effectuer des mesures au laser dans les
cavernes lna note les résultats pour
mesurer l'ensemble de la grotte
il faut enregistrer 2000 points à l'aide
d'un équipement spécial
ça y est oui c'est fait on se trouve
maintenant sur un éboulis qui s'est
formé après l'effondrement d'une partie
du plafond
avec le temps ces roches seront emportés
par les eaux souterraines
cette grotte va cesser d'exister nous
avons donc une chance unique de l'avoir
à l'eau pas de lumière ou entendu
j'arrivais tout remplacer les ampoules
d'accord l'égard de son responsable de
la sécurité à l'intérieur de la grotte
chaque jour bien avant l'arrivée des
touristes il s'assure qu'il n'y ait pas
d'effondrement sur le sentier
touristique qu'il n'y ait pas de
problème avec l'éclairage et vérifie
l'état des voûtes et voilà maintenant
c'est bon on procède ainsi tous les
jours environ cent mille touristes
viennent voir la grotte chaque année
c'est deux fois plus que la population
totale de koungou re les roches noires
et friable ont été enlevés à l'aide de
cette balise je peux observer la
subsidence des roches cet appareil
détecte les fissures quand un tel
décalage se produit il faut alors
renforcer le bloc de gypse
une tige d'ancrage relie la roche
détaché au plafond solide ce type de
fixation est considéré comme le meilleur
pour la grande foule bourg une telle
plateforme pèse cinq tonnes toutes les
voûtes au dessus du sentier touristique
sont maintenant assurés sauf la grotte a
été ouverte aux touristes
il y à plus d'une centaine d'années et
il n'y a eu aucun accident depuis ce
jour j'étais étudiant je suis venu ici
quand j'ai vu ces espaces et toutes ces
formations de l'as j'ai été frappé par
sa beauté cette énergie c'est puissant
dix ans ont passé et la grotte est
devenu une partie d'eux-mêmes
comme il est difficile de se frayer un
passage ici on y est presque
pendant ce temps le géophysicien youri
stepanov et nicolas et maksimovic
ingerop spécialisée dans la topographie
karstique ont atteint la grotte colère
il y à là non seulement des cristaux des
plus bizarres mais aussi des glaces qui
sont là depuis des siècles elles ne font
ni en hiver il n'y en été ici on peut
apprécier toute la splendeur des
cristaux les scientifiques ont commencé
à utiliser des géoradar pour mesurer la
glace à l'intérieur de la grotte
la méthode s'est avérée très efficace
ici on se déplace en rentrant puis on
glisse vers le bas afin de mesurer
toutes les irrégularités des formations
de glace
priori et nikolay on pensait que si cet
équipement était utilisé pour étudier
les glace en antarctique
il devrait être possible de faire de
même dans une grotte
c est difficile à croire mais jusqu'à
encore récemment on utilisait une simple
fort aux à glace pour mesurer son
épaisseur avec un géoradar il faut peu
de temps pour mesurer la surface de la
glace à l'aide de cet appareil les
scientifiques ont découvert que à
certains endroits l'épaisseur de la
glace atteignait 6 m l'état de la glace
à l'intérieur de la grotte dépend des
température maintenue par l'aération
naturel quand il fait plus froid à la
surface la grotte accumulent plus de
froid la glace commence à se former et
la grotte gèle tout ce processus dépend
de l'environnement externe
on pourrait dire que la grotte ressemble
un climatiseur naturel prend des mesures
tout les ennuis
on peut alors comprendre comment
s'effectue le glaçage et la faune on
peut même en tirer des conclusions sur
le changement climatique
à ce jour les spéléo notes n'ont jamais
fait de plonger dans la zone protégée de
la grotte pour la première fois une
équipe de scientifiques spécialisés en
recherche sous marine de la société
russe de géographie
plonge dans une zone très peu étudiée du
trésor de koungou re l'océan arctique
comme on l'appelle ici
les plongeurs ont établi que ce lac
souterrain était le plus grand du
système lacustre de koungou re il fait
60 mètres de long soit deux fois plus
que le plus grand lac de la partie
touristique quelqu'un qui a été formé
comme spéléo note peut travailler
littéralement partout y compris comme
secouriste sur les lieux d'un naufrage
ces gens peuvent tout faire
ce groupe a déjà exploré des dizaines de
lacs souterrains et pas seulement en
russie
il étudie les grottes du monde entier et
la plongée spéléologique est l'un des
métiers les plus dangereux
les plongeurs ne savent pas ce qui les
attend sous l'eau mais le frisson de la
découverte est d'autant plus fort il ya
un passage de 15 mètres de long est à
peu près un mètre cinquante de haut
il est assez 3 il va par là on a trouvé
ce qu'on voulait bien joué les gars et
c'est la dixième découverte de dennis
michael ioffe il lui a fallu trois ans
pour se préparer à cette plongée les
entraînements avaient lieu dans la
grotte ordinn sky a non loin de koungou
re
il lui a fallu développer toutes les
compétences nécessaires car ici la plus
infime erreur vous coûter la vie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tout comme au bon vieux temps
les affaires vont bien lors de la fête
de maslenitsa les habitants font leurs
adieux à l'hiver crêpes et souvenirs
disparaissent rapidement il y a beaucoup
de gens talentueux artiste céramiste
sculpteur sur pierre ah koon lourd
depuis sa fondation au xviie siècle
koungou re a toujours été un centre
important des échanges commerciaux au
xvième siècle le conquérant de la
sibérie hier mac est arrivé ici avec son
armée ses temps perdus
le chef kozak a décidé de s'installer un
temps ici avant de repartir pour la
sibérie il a fondé une colonie sion la
montagne de glace
des maisons ont été construites pour
l'hiver ils ont découvert qu'il y avait
une grotte sous cette montagne les
troupes de yermak l'utilisaient comme un
réfrigérateur naturel
les profondeurs mystérieuse de la grotte
attirer beaucoup de jean pierre legrand
lui même a ordonné qu'on dessine une
carte de la grotte
cette dernière a été terminé au 17e
siècle et est devenue la première carte
des grottes souterraines au monde à la
fin du 19e siècle
le natif de kumbo alexandre klebnikov
est devenu le premier guide à organiser
des tours dans la grotte à l'aide de
cette carte
malgré sa beauté l'endroit renfermait
beaucoup de danger
ce n'était pas suffisant pour faire peur
à la princesse allemande victoria ii
battenberg et sa fille louise quelques
temps plus tard à louise par son mariage
devenait reine de suède
on dit qu'elle a fait se veut sur la
pierre qui chante la carte de la grotte
est constamment mis à jour en 1964 le
premier plan de la grotte avec des
photographies a été réalisée mais la
science a fait de grands progrès depuis
nicolas et pancho cov développe
maintenant un modèle 3d de ce labyrinthe
souterrain
ils entrent les données de la grotte de
la tour dans un programme spécial le
modèle 3d permet de clarifier les
positions relatives des grottes et
d'établir leurs dimensions maximales
une telle analyse aide à déterminer la
probabilité d'un effondrement
ces informations sont importantes non
seulement pour la grotte mais également
pour la ville ce les deux amis dit il
faut étudier les processus karstique
dans la grotte de koungou ils ont créé
un phénomène naturel tout à fait
incroyable une vraie curiosité mais à
cause de la qualification qui se produit
sous la ville il est nécessaire
d'investir beaucoup d'argent pour
reloger les personnes qui vivent dans
des endroits sûrs il faut construire là
où le sol est stable ce tas
les recherches scientifiques montrent
que les deux tiers des éboulements de
terrain de koungou re sont causées par
la qualification les fissures de ce
bâtiment ne cesse de s'aggraver depuis
quelques années on a dû installer des
poutrelles d'acier pour empêcher
l'effondrement des murs et du toit de
nouvelles fissures apparaissent
cela signifie que cela bouge en dessous
de la maison des contes récits je me
plie à une grande fissure ici garde
l'oci un filtre d'abord à l'humidité
provoque le pourrissement et
l'effritement des taxes ma copine le mur
de la cuisine ne tient plus et il y à
des sourires dans les chambres a comme
le baiia se décolle beauté - chez emylia
une conduite d'eau ici lorsque la
température baisse et stocker l'eau dans
le tuyau gel et votre visite et vous
voyez la cuisse ce format j'ai une autre
fissure sur le côté
nous l'avons embauché show vie nous y
avons misé une balise elle s'est déjà
fait les cantons a construit cet
immeuble un lac karstique était en train
de se former
le sol sous le bâtiment a commencé à
s'affaisser comme s'il y avait un
entonnoir sans fond les murs se sont
lézardées les locataires ont été évacués
et des scientifiques se sont mises au
travail
la maison est située dans le centre
ville
des fissures sont apparues parce qu'il y
à une cavité juste ici en dessous de la
maison
alors voici comment le problème a été
résolu
les scientifiques ont été chargés de
mener des recherches ils ont travaillé
ici pendant deux ans les résultats
obtenus ont servi de base pour un
nouveau plan général de là
aujourd'hui tous les bâtiments sont
construits selon les recommandations des
scientifiques
détail étonnant les cette cathédrale de
la ville repose sur un terrain solide
alors même qu'elles ont été construites
longtemps avant que les gens aient
commencé à étudier le karst ironie du
sort c'est grâce à ces formations
karstiques que kung ur a pu préserver
son aspect de vieille ville marchande
il est interdit de construire de grands
bâtiments dans les vieux quartiers à
cause des risques d'effondrement la
grotte de glace qui menace d'engloutir
la ville présente toujours un grand
intérêt scientifique pour passer d'une
grotte à l'autre on a besoin de ramper
ou parfois de descendre la tête en bas
mètre après mètre grotte après grotte un
spéléologue expérimenté est à la tête du
groupe il faut ramper sur le côté en
appuyant sur vos jambes ou contre le mur
opposé
il y aura à laxou wauquiez à trois
mètres de profondeur
s'il vous plaît soyez très prudents ne
tombez pas et ne le sait pas tomber vos
équipements olga qu'adobe sky a est à
l'aise dans la zone protégée
même quand les lumières sont éteintes à
elle remarque immédiatement les moindres
changements
la zone protégée a été découverte par
accident en 1935 une expédition a eu
lieu au cours de laquelle un de ses
membres a remarqué un trou qui menait
vers des tunnels et des grottes qui
s'étendait sur plus de trois kilomètres
il y avait aussi de nombreux lacs
on appelle ça le tuyaux d'orgue ce sont
des canaux verticaux qui relie les
grottes à la surface ils peuvent faire
jusqu'à 22 mètres l'équivalent d'un
bâtiment de sept étages
il y à 13 grotte dans cette zone le gip
se détache et des morceaux pente depuis
les voûtes pesant au moins 5 tonnes les
premiers explorateurs ont été tellement
frappé par la beauté de cette partie de
la grotte qu'ils ont décidé de la
conserver tel quel de gypse sont très
rares c'est l'un des endroits où son
poteau gauche
la grotte la plus célèbre on peut voir
des pestos se trouve mexique
là bas ils peuvent faire jusqu'à 14
mètres dans notre grotte ils font 5 cm
mais ils sont très beaux
[Musique]
nicolaï pankov poursuit ses recherches
depuis toujours les cavernes ne sont pas
les seuls à attirer les gens on veut
aussi toujours en savoir un peu plus sur
leurs habitants
il ya longtemps les gens croyaient qu
ici habiter un animal ressemblant à un
mammouth et qui se nourrissait de terre
créant ces cavités
mais en réalité il n'ya que de très
petites créatures tout à fait
inoffensive et dont les ancêtres
vivaient ici quand existait encore la
mer préhistorique de perm
ce crustacé peut atteindre jusqu'à 2 cm
de long il se nourrit des matières
organiques qui entrent dans les bassins
pendant les inondations
il n'a pas d'yeux et ne montrent jamais
à la surface il a été nommé d'après le
premier gardien et guide de la grotte
amphipodes khlebnikov quelle chance pour
nicolas et olga ils ont réussi à en
attraper un descendant nous priant c'est
génial tu es contente maintenant c'est
magnifique gagné tout ce qu'ils meurent
souvent dans nos piège parce qu'il
manque d'air mais ici il faut tout noté
c'est une espèce très intéressant c'est
le seul organisme de la région de perm
qui s'est adapté à la cavernicoles selon
théorie ils se seraient infiltrés dans
les eaux souterraines au début de l'âge
de glace a légué le froid a contribué à
une prolifération plus rapide sous terre
et le meilleur spéléo photographe
tchèque
igor arnat est venu prendre des
photographies de l'une des plus grandes
grottes karstique de l'oral le mur de
cette coursive porte une inscription
faite en 1914 par la princesse victoria
ii battenberg et sa fille louise au fil
du temps ces gros cristaux de glace qui
couvre le plafond prennent des formes
différentes
ils ressemblent à des roses ou à des
labyrinthes à facettes
lorsque la température baisse d'autres
plaques apparaissent ou les cavités
s'approfondissent de grands cristaux de
glace couvre le plafond et forme une
frange et quand il fait encore plus
froid
il se transforme en aiguille de glace
ils atteignent leur taille maximum au
mois de mars
seuls ceux qui viennent ici peuvent
admirer ses trésors de glace j'ai visité
de nombreux endroits si vingt dernières
années je me suis rendu dans des voies
très dangereuse mais je dirais dire que
je suis absolument stupéfait par ce que
je vois ici la fois comme photographe
mais comme se plaît aux touristes
endurci là pour les corridas fantastique
je suis la reine du froid et des glaces
dalle je vais vous conduire à travers
trois royaumes
le royaume du froid c'est mon préféré le
royaume de la pierre et le royaume de
l'osce soyez les bienvenus
[Musique]
certains sont tellement impressionnés
par la beauté et les mystères de koungou
re qu'ils sont même prêts à faire face
au froid et à l'obscurité pour prouver
leurs sentiments
ces jeunes mariés ont décidé de célébrer
leur mariage dans la grotte
quant à voici notre pierre lapierre de
l'amour je fais un voeu dans cette
grotte il ya deux ans oui devinez quoi
mais poser certains deviner poster
draghi s'il vous plaît venez ici pour
enregistrer votre mariage dans la grotte
de glace de koungou la grotte de corail
a été nommé ainsi parce que ses murs et
ses voûtes ressemble à un récif une
salle pour les visiteurs a été
construite en 1984 c'est ici dans l'un
des plus beaux endroits de la caverne
qui riina et alexandre ont décidé de se
marier
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le bisou le bisou le bisou
[Applaudissements]
la magie des lacs souterrains et des
immenses grotte tout comme la poésie
éternel des glaces font plonger les gens
dans un monde ancien et fantastique
des visites guidées s'effectue ici
depuis presque cent ans valentin rap
continue la tradition du premier guide
alexandre khlebnikov la grotte et sa
seconde maison
et il raconte avec plaisir les légendes
locales un dauphin âge est ici en quête
de sa sirène bien-aimée mais il n'a
trouvé personne et son amour là
pétrifiée celui qui cherche son amour
doit taper sur cette pierre est ainsi il
trouvera sa bien aimée
dans le passé en utilisaient des lampes
à pétrole des torches ou des cierges
pour illuminer la note à la fin du xxème
siècle l'électricité a été installé
aujourd'hui cette procession aux
flambeaux dans la grotte n'est qu'une
occasion spéciale
un hommage aux premiers guides alexandre
club nikov grâce à lui les touristes
peuvent aller au centre de la terre tous
les joueurs il a accompagné les
touristes dans la grotte jusqu'à sa mort
alors même qu'il était presque aveugle
il reliait le passé le présent et
l'avenir il aider les autres à ressentir
ce processus perpétuelle apercevoir ce
lien éternel entre un monde souterrain
mystérieux et l'agitation de la vie à la
surface
[Musique]